[Music]
so uh here at the pet home show uh we
love video games that's true and we
wanted to shine a spotlight on some of
our favorite lesser known video games
because I don't know if you guys know
this but here at the show we have access
to all the
[Applause]
games all right so first up we have from
the makers of Angry Birds it's sexually
frustrated
birds that explains why they're angry
that that'll that'll that's the first
one we like to frontload it with a real
Banger you know something that really
put us on sure footing for the rest of
the bit usually the second one's not as
strong but don't worry the wave of
laughter from the first one will still
be paying
dividends so I'm just going to relax
kick my shoes off and bask in the
success of sexually frustrated
birds and just merge seamlessly into the
second one which as I said won't be as
good so following up uh sexually
frustrated Birds
okay we have the Legend of Zelda sorry
for the confusion the main character's
name is actually
link yeah
okay you're welcome everyone dressing up
as Link at
ComicCon uh so in the Lego Family of
games the Lego Family you have Lego sha
Shank
Redemption
I wish I could tell you Lego Andy fought
the good
fight and the Lego sisters let him
be uh here's one we actually already did
Kirby what the am
I but I don't know if you know this
there's now a sequel Kirby 2 seriously
guys what the am I like a balloon or a
pillow but then I eat things I want
answers little guy wants
answers ah this is a fun one for the
late night drinking alone
crowd Words With Friends with Benefits
that's a that's a good
one yeah and finally from the makers of
Mario party we have Mario key
[Laughter]
party
yeah sorry what the hell is Luigi doing
there you can't come to a key party
alone you got to be part of a couple
luig I help you save the princess you
let Luigi
[Music]
watch